another one of your cast mates on the
Fosters Noah sent nao having a huge
moment with his career right now
have you spoken with him recently yeah
it's pretty insane I mean he actually
came to guest star on the trouble yes
and yes I'm very excited about that but
twelve boys are left before dropped that
week that he was on set so I literally
was there when I saw it kind of happened
overnight and it was so insane but he's
he's such an amazing guy and he's so
deserving so I'm so happy for him I mean
you have been friends with him for a
long time your brother on the show he's
now being thought of as like the hunk of
all the air that's boyfriend what do you
make of all of this it's kind of crazy I
mean it's it's weird I mean like I yeah
I know him so well and um I mean yeah
I've seen this too the movie and I'm
like oh yeah I get it I have a crush on
Peter Kaczynski convinced ki know
friends that are literally coming out oh
oh my gosh yes literally like let me
slide into those dm's I'm like I got you
and I don't know well look i always say
that i think the best relationships are
formed when like a friend says i've got
someone for you like do you ever play
matchmaker with him every girl is
clamoring oh I haven't played matchmaker
with him no not yet at least
not yet but you know why not you have
some I know but you know what we are
twins I got that celebrity going so as
soon as I find her I will let him know
what kind of woman do you think he's
looking for like okay he's told me about
like some of his dates I mean and he's
like his first date with the girl was
they went on a rooftop and they
exchanged books and they read they're
together for hours so she's definitely
got to be like cerebral oh yeah yeah
she's got to be able to go on hikes with
him and watch the sunset I mean who
wouldn't want to do that but like you
know but she's gonna be down she's got
to be like a woman of the world for sure
I'm on set working with someone who you
might or might not know oh
it's my sister fear so good good trouble
y'all here we go you're gonna see a lot
of familiar faces on katrell which is
really fun because I mean it's it's set
five years in the future
I mean picks up a couple weeks left
after the series finale so it's really
nice to see where all of your favorite
characters have kind of gone in their
lives and you'll kind of see them in a
different light for sure so hey soos
you know this is I don't wanna give too
much away but I mean he is definitely in
a new place in life and yeah everyone's
very grown up and kind of becoming their
own humans for sure we're gonna kind of
see all of you in a different light
absolutely 100% but I mean he's always
gonna come in and stir something up you
know just because they are twins and
they are always fighting but then
they're always you know he's the only
one that can actually get away with all
of that because you know it's a lot of
times Mariana needs to be told all of
these things yes and it can come off as
very harsh but when it's her twin
brother he can easily get away with it
right well he's brings it back down to
earth you should be proud of yourself I
am okay but you know my sister
Mariana you had your chapters doing the
Fosters together you close that book and
then you got a chance to work with him
again on a different set what was it
like to be together again it was really
fun I mean and then you know for
everyone to I mean it was like a little
bit of a piece of home yeah you know
because it was on an it was a new
chapter and it was almost like going to
college or moving to a new city and then
having your family come to visit which
is always so fun and yeah just just
genuine fun on set yeah
[Music]